an extreme avalanche danger warning is
in effect for parts of Colorado this
morning the state has seen a record
number of avalanches including one
yesterday that was as wide as a football
field measured from goal line to goal
line they are creating treacherous
driving conditions David beg no is in
Colorado with what's being done to
prevent an avalanche disaster it was
massive engulfing highway 91 in Colorado
yesterday trees snapped like toothpicks
at least four drivers were in their
vehicles as the Avalanche buried their
cars in snow no one was hurt Colorado's
Department of Transportation says the
Avalanche was 100 yards wide and up to
15 feet deep earlier in the day there
were at least six other avalanches in
Colorado including one that ruptured a
gas line these avalanches come just days
after this monster snow slide on Sunday
that happened not far from here it swept
vehicles off the road there were no
injuries then either but one Avalanche
last weekend was deadly a skier was
buried in three feet of snow officials
want to prevent more tragedy by
triggering controlled avalanches just
like this one that happened on Tuesday
right now there are four areas in
Colorado's central mountains that are
under the highest danger rating for
avalanches this is the first time that's
happened since forecasts began back in
1973 to actually be around and
avalanches and stuff like that I mean I
have never seen something like this ever
for CBS this morning I'm David beg no in
Denver Colorado